are you guys familiar what's going on in
the metaverse i actually have a
metaverse property there it is she's got
a metaverse property
here we go so um bill gates recently
predicted that by 2026 we'll be having
meetings in the meta
instead of on zoom and we'll pay for our
own avatar skins
uh someone will own that office space
apparently and we'll probably need to
pay them rent so you're excited about
this metaverse tell us about this office
you have in the metaverse
i don't have an office i have an
apartment in the middle okay explain
that
so basically what i mean it's obviously
still new and i'm learning a lot
but um so basically if you're like one
of the first people to like you get in
there like buying the property it's
going to increase over time like the
internet it's not stopping
anything like virtual like it's going to
keep going progressing progressing so
like that's kind of the thing right now
like people are buying it so then like
they can eventually sell it higher
you know so is it is it is it an asset
or is it
to me it almost feels to me it almost
feels like fashion like
i i think i mean it's like you got to
take a risk right you don't know you
kind of got to take a risk if it's low
right now and potentially it can be like
worth something
i think you should probably take a risk
with it um that's the same thing with
nfts and stuff right now too i kind of
feel like you don't even know it's all
digital you don't know where that money
is really going well if there's somebody
that can probably make a couple comments
about nfts it's our friend marco here
what's your thoughts on the benefits
nfts i mean incorporating real estate i
think obviously the metaverse is here to
stay for for a little bit you know
that's just like the whole trend and
there's so many big players getting into
the space and huge companies putting so
much money in that i doubt it's just
gonna like disappear
yeah will things uh you know how many of
those platforms will actually like stay
you know maybe maybe a limited amount
but you just have to you have to know
who you're getting involved with who are
the creators of these companies
um you know what what's the actual like
goal what's the end point with the land
but yeah i think you know you're getting
in early like it's like a startup right
so just because you're buying land and
metaverse it's just like investing in a
company
um you know let's say early on and you
know i'm i'm a partner in nft platform
so i've i've learned somewhat i haven't
gotten that crazy in the metaverse even
though we did buy
um a piece of land to build an office in
sandbox oh nice yeah but uh yeah i'm not
hands-on with that stuff i try to focus
on on real estate shout out to eternity
shout out to ethernet nick rose okay
yeah tiff you're probably thinking these
people are freaking crazy
tiffany go off and tell chief crazy
i can't wrap my head around buying land
in a virtual place
um i think i'd rather invest my money in
real land
in our real world but i mean i don't
you're just old and
you know i don't get it i don't get it
and that's okay
but if the money comes but if there's
listen i'm all about investing and
taking risks though will i put money
into it yeah am i going to buy
ethereum and and nfts and all the things
yeah i'm gonna have like some you know
small portfolio of it absolutely but for
me personally i'm gonna keep my real
estate focus on the real estate that i'm
currently selling let me try to change
your mind let's say okay
marco
gives you a call and goes hey tiff i
have this
25 million virtual property in the
metaverse and i can't think of anybody
that i would rather
sell it than you i'm gonna sell that
change
okay that's it
[Music]